[Música]
por primera vez desde el inicio de la
invasión a ucrania rusia atacó
posiciones en el oeste del país cerca de
las fronteras con polonia y rumanía la
estrategia del kremlin es dificultar la
logística y transporte de suministros
desde países de la unión europea
la guerra en ucrania ha hecho que la
inflación se dispare en varias regiones
del planeta afectando a países de la
unión europea naciones de latinoamérica
y eeuu entre otros se prevé que los
efectos económicos a nivel global duren
por meses
el palacio de la moneda en chile ya
tiene a su nuevo ocupante gabriel boric
asumió el cargo en la sede del
legislativo en valparaíso y
posteriormente se desplazó a santiago
donde pronunció su primer discurso en
medio de los vítores de miles de
personas
[Música]
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentín a torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos con la invasión
rusa y ucrania por primera vez desde el
inicio de la ofensiva se registraron
ataques en el oeste de esta nación lo
que aumenta la atención entre las
naciones de la otan entretanto un centro
turístico vacacional en lituania se
transformó en un lugar de acogida para
niños huérfanos que huyen de la guerra
melissa chávez rincón tiene la historia
niños de un orfanato en el este de
ucrania vivían en constante terror días
después de la invasión rusa los
bombardeos amenazaban sus vidas
alexandra una niña de 14 años cuenta lo
que tuvieron que vivir
tal que querían bombardear la
instalación militar cercana pero
afortunadamente terminó bien para
nosotros fue aterrador escuchamos los
misiles pasar no los vi pero hacían un
parpadeo de luz en la oscuridad no le
voy a dar a su auto poca da la decisión
de irse no fue fácil pero el personal
del orfanato no vio otra opción
cuando nos dimos cuenta que el conflicto
no iba a terminar pronto y que muchas
veces los niños tenían que ir al sótano
a refugiarse cuando encendían las
sirenas tomamos la decisión de irnos y
llevarlos a un lugar seguro
los 44 niños del orfanato emprendieron
un viaje de 36 horas en autobús
atravesando su país hasta llegar a
lituania en donde un centro turístico se
convirtió en un refugio para ellos
en versión sabemos lo devastadora que
puede ser una invasión devastar a la
vida de las personas durante muchas
generaciones entonces todas lituania
ahora experimenta un tsunami de buena
voluntad en apoyo a ucrania
tsunami of good world and support for
crane ahora la preocupación de las
autoridades locales es ofrecerles
educación y la mejor atención
queremos preparar a la comunidad escolar
para que sepa cómo tratarlos y
aceptarlos queremos resolverlo para que
los niños se sientan cómodos y seguros
desde el 24 de febrero cuando inició el
conflicto
2.5 millones de personas entre ellos un
millón de niños han huido del país
buscando seguridad y protección
la guerra en ucrania le pasará factura
al mundo la inflación se ha disparado en
varias regiones del planeta afectando a
países de la unión europea de
latinoamérica a eeuu y por supuesto a
aquellos que están más cerca del
conflicto los detalles los tienen juan
pabló lucumí el mundo pagará un alto
costo por la guerra en ucrania la
invasión rusa sobre suelo ucraniano ha
causado un aumento en los precios de la
energía y las materias primas en muchos
países del mundo la tasa inflacionaria
de la eurozona en febrero fue del 5,8
por ciento interanual una de las más
altas comparada con el mismo período del
año anterior que fue del 0,9 por ciento
interanual en eeuu la situación es aún
más preocupante pues en febrero el país
ya registraba una tasa de inflación
interanual del 7 9% una cifra no vista
desde enero de 1982 y ahora con la
guerra en ucrania el panorama parece
empeorar
desde el momento en que putin puso sus
más de 150.000 tropas en la frontera
ucraniana el precio de la gasolina en
enero subió 75 centavos putin comenzó a
acumular las tropas a lo largo de la
frontera y adivinen que el mundo se dio
cuenta y entonces putin invadió no se
equivoquen la inflación es en gran parte
culpa de putin tan solo esta semana el
fondo monetario internacional aseguró
que rebajará su previsión de crecimiento
mundial para el próximo mes debido a los
efectos indirectos de la crisis
ucraniana previsiones económicas que ya
habían sido rebajadas por culpa de la
pandemia del cob y 19
las repercusiones en los países vecinos
también son importantes en particular en
los países más integrados en la economía
ucraniana y rusa los principales canales
en estos efectos indirectos hacia los
países vecinos hacia central el cáucaso
moldavia
según el organismo las repercusiones
económicas de la crisis ucraniana se
verán de manera evidente en tres puntos
claves el aumento de los precios de las
materias primas el impacto sobre los
ingresos el impacto sobre las
condiciones financieras y la confianza
empresarial y mientras las sanciones
contra rusia aumentan putin ha advertido
que si occidente se sigue entrometiendo
en sus objetivos habrá consecuencias
para los mercados mundiales
ya muchos ciudadanos de los países
afectados se preguntan que van a hacer
sus gobiernos con la constante alza de
precios sobre todo cuando buscan cortar
los lazos con rusia un país que
suministra energía a varios de ellos en
otras noticias india disparó un misil
contra pakistán y calificó los hechos de
accidente durante una operación de
mantenimiento pakistán condenó el evento
diciendo que hubiese podido tener
consecuencias trágicas y acusó a su
vecino de violar su espacio aéreo más
detalles en el informe de gabriel coll
son un accidente técnico durante una
operación de mantenimiento es lo que
ella afirmó del misil que se estrelló en
el este de pakistán cerca de mian channu
el jueves por la noche el objeto de alto
velocidad que no estaba armado fue
disparado desde la ciudad de sirte en el
norte de la india según las autoridades
paquistaníes
el misil cambio de dirección inicial y
violó el espacio aéreo de pakistán no
hubo ningún muerto o herido pero algunas
propiedades civiles fueron dañadas work
con el incidente
pérez for the links to explain sea cual
sea la causa de este incidente
corresponde a los indios explicarlo sin
embargo muestra su desprecio por la
seguridad aérea y refleja muy mal su
destreza tecnológica y su eficiencia en
los procedimientos el incidente podría
haber dado lugar a una importante
catástrofe aérea así como a víctimas
civiles en tierra soltera en un mayor
desgaste de las civil incultos con crowe
por su lado ya dijo lamentar el evento
el ministro indio de defensa afirmó que
tomaba con serie a la situación y que
había ordenado una investigación de alto
nivel sobre los hechos
históricamente los dos países
fronterizos han pasado por periodos de
fuertes tensiones
particularmente alrededor del territorio
de cachemira que se disputan ya se
enfrentaron en varios conflictos desde
1947 y ambos son potencias nucleares
vamos hasta chile el nuevo presidente
gabriel boric se dirigió a la ciudadanía
en su primer discurso como mandatario el
jefe de estado pidió unidad de todos los
sectores sociales y políticos para
avanzar aseguró que escuchará a sus
detractores y les garantizó su derecho a
protestar
añadió que en chileno se repetirán las
violaciones a los derechos humanos que
ha vivido el pueblo hasta ahora
seré el presidente de todos los chilenos
y chilenas y escucharé siempre las
críticas constructivas y las propuestas
de quienes piensan distinto a nosotros
los que siempre siempre tendrán
garantizada la libertad y el derecho de
disentir
necesitamos una constitución que nos una
que sintamos como propia una
constitución que a diferencia de la de
la que fue impuesta a sangre fuego y
fraude por la dictadura nazca en
democracia
de manera paritaria
con participación de los pueblos
indígenas
una constitución que sea para el
presente y para el futuro
desde santiago patricia luna
corresponsal de france 24 nos dio más
detalles de la jornada que vivió el
nuevo presidente chileno
fue una jornada llena de simbolismo
lleno de momentos emotivos el cambio de
mando fue especialmente diferente a
otros que habíamos visto será el octavo
desde que desde 1990 vimos a un
presidente que llegó sin corbata muchos
de sus ministros también lo hicieron en
un gesto muy simbólico para este acto
protocolar miradas cómplices
emotividad y también un discurso en el
que el juramento ante el pueblo y ante
los pueblos de chile reconociendo así el
rol que también tendrán los pueblos
originarios en este nuevo gobierno que
como dijo el presidente desde el balcón
en los protagonistas de este gobierno
será también la ciudadanía la gente de
la calle un gobierno que quiere estar
conectado con los intereses y las
demandas de su pueblo finalizamos con
algunas de las imágenes que nos dejó la
jornada de posesión de gabriel boric
font el presidente más joven en la
historia de chile
ah
con estas imágenes nos despedimos a
ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en francés 24
[Música]